Blue's Clues star Steve Burns was pretty much
every late '90s kid's pretend best friend
as he took them on colorful new mysteries
around the house and outside with his trusty pooch pal.
The show, which centered on Steve and his
dog Blue making an interactive adventure of
even the simplest things like checking the
mail, ranked right up there with popular contemporaries
like Barney, the Teletubbies, and Winnie the
Pooh.
So, when Steve suddenly disappeared from the
hit program and was replaced at the height
of its popularity, the rumor mill went haywire,
even going so far as to declare the young
show host had died to explain his unexpected
departure.
Luckily, Steve is still alive and well … even
though his former fans might not be able to
spot him walking around town.
"I am completely unrecognizable now."
What he's been up to since taking his leave
of the small screen might just surprise you.
Here's what's become of former Blue's Clues
star Steve Burns.
Exit signs
The obvious first question most people have
about what happened to Steve Burns is
"Why did the guy leave the show right in the middle
of its prime?"
No, he didn't have some other lucrative offer
luring him away, nor did he fall into a pit of depression.
But he did start to lose his hair and watched
some behind-the-scenes creatives take their leave, too.
So for him, it was just time to go when he
did.
There were also a few practical considerations
at play.
"It was crazy.
It was awesome, but it was not exactly the
kind of thing that would get me a date."
One of the other factors that had Steve questioning
his reality while he was such a central kid's
show icon is whether the wacky messages he
was delivering to so many millions of little
ones were actually worthy of their attention.
"'You can do anything that you want to do.'
But I couldn't help thinking, you know, is
that true?"
Still alive
Blue's Clues might've come along during the
advent of the internet age, but pop culture
urban legends still loomed large at the time.
Somehow, rumors spread like wildfire that
Steve died of a drug overdose or a grisly
car wreck in between Seasons 4 and 5, even
though in the last episode of Season 4, Steve
introduced his own replacement — Steve's
brother Joe, played by Donovan Patton for
the final two seasons of the show.
In 2017, he spoke to Tech Insider about the
persistent death hoax:
"To be rumored to be dead for 15 years starts
to feel disturbingly like a cultural preference."
Nowadays, Burns makes light of the rumors
with the Twitter handle @SteveBurnsAlive — to
both have fun with the misunderstanding and
clear it up.
Making art
Although Burns hasn't nearly re-claimed the
same level of fame that he had on Blue's Clues,
he hasn't shelved his stack of old headshots
entirely just yet.
He appeared on-stage for The Moth to wax poetic
with a true-life telling of his time as a
children's TV show star and also starred in
The Flaming Lips' weird space-centric holiday video.
He's also been seen starring on webisodes
of small YouTube shows like The Professionals
and even appearing alongside another blue
storytelling pal for Bizarro Studio's Herman's
Scary Stories series.
Of course, those cameos alone probably aren't
enough to pay the bills, and his Blue's Clues
residuals can't last forever …
"I wanted to know how you've been doing with
my money.
Well?"
"Broke!"
So, Burns has steadily been moving forward
on that music career he's been working on
for so long all the while.
"I'm just a boring example of everybody else."
He fulfilled his own childhood dream by releasing
his own record and, when his solo act wasn't
hacking it, he linked up with The Flaming
Lips alum Steven Drozd to begin working on an album.
Thanks to the popularity of Blue's Clues with
a producer's kid, Steve was well known before
he ever made his big pitch.
Hey, it's not like he hadn't shown off his
skills on the show already.
The two have since formed a project called
Steven Steven and put together a trippy kids'
album titled Foreverywhere, which drops in
February, 2017.
Free time
Although his music making and random acting
jobs are fun enough, Steve Burns also has
enough time to bring his fans in on some of
his other obsessions, like taking pictures
of every Walmart sign he sees and, yes, even
the occasional bit of nostalgia and puns about
his former life as Steve of Blue's Clues.
Although the show is now far in the past for
Steve Burns, he does keep a few reminders
lying around the house for old time's sake.
"The chair sits in my study…
I love it.
I have the original notebook.
I have the first three clues, which is cool."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!